[Musique]
bonsoir merci de nous rejoindre pour une
nouvelle édition du journal de la
rédaction de tv fils votre journal
d'actualités locales
voici les titres de cette édition du 8
décembre 2016 l usine d'eau potable de
louveciennes est en train de finaliser
la construction d'une nouvelle unité de
décarbonation cela aura une incidence
directe si vous résidez à saint quentin
en yvelines à votre eau sera bientôt
wasquehal que noël approche si vous
n'avez pas encore trouvé le sapin
parfait nous vous donnerons quelques
conseils et puis côté repas pour les
fêtes cette année la mode est à la
viande mature et ce sera à découvrir
dans quelques minutes
et puis le skipper yvelinois du vendée
globe éric bellion victime d'une avarie
sur son safran tribord le bateau s'est
couché dans une rafale à plus de 50
noeuds aujourd'hui c'était le lancement
du ski cube cet incubateur pour
l'entrepreneuriat dédié aux start up
pour favoriser leur développement
ecoutez jean michel fourgous et le vice
président chargé du développement
économique à saint quentin en yvelines
il est à l'origine de ce projet et c'est
au micro de semaine vendeur alors ce
ch'ti cube c'est un petit peu votre bébé
mais écoutez la crée son entreprise se
doit être le bébé de la france où
d'entière bien sûr à saint quentin
oui de deuxième pib par habitant en
france après paris on se doit bien
entendu de l'accélérer aussi de profiter
de cette qualité des réseaux
d'entreprise et de l'offrir
bien sûr aux jeunes créateurs
d'entreprise assez de saint quentin
donc voilà le ski cube c'est avant tout
un accélérateur de croissance
un accélérateur de de contact des
changes en même temps très rapidement ce
pe de concentration de savoir faire
qu'on leur donne encore avec dans les
six mois c'est quasiment l'équivalent
d'une grande école de commerce cité donc
c'est un réseau c'est des contacts
qu'ils ont un animateur ils ont un cube
alliance qui est quand même le numéro 1
de l'animation de deux incubateurs et
dès ce jeudi vous découvrirez sur notre
antenne une nouvelle édition du 7 8 et
co consacrée exclusivement à sun ce
nouvel outil pour le développement des
entreprises une émission à voir
également en replay sur notre site
internet dans un tout autre domaine à
présent vous aurez bientôt une eau moins
calcaire chez vous l'usiné d'eau potable
de louveciennes est en train de
finaliser la construction d'une nouvelle
unité de dépôt décarbonatation sa
disgrâce après c'est saint nicolas c'est
un dispositif qui va permettre de rendre
à partir de février 2010 est l'eau
potable d'une grande partie de
l'agglomération deux fois quelqu'un
c'est cela alors on l'a compris les
termes sont assez technique mais
concrètement la dureté de l'eau qui
indique la teneur en calcaire va
diminuer de 50 % pour s'établir à 20
degrés français c'est l'expression
exacte ainsi quatre cent mille habitants
vont profiter de l'une des zones les
moins calcaire à d'île de france à
partir de début 2010 est et cela
concernera notamment plusieurs communes
de saint quentin en yvelines montigny
trapel en cours la verrière villepreux
guyancourt et voisins le bretonneux une
grande partie de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines donc mais
l'intérêt derrière tout ça pour les
habitants alors contrairement à
certaines idées reçues le calcaire est
utile pour la qualité de votre os donc
les avantages ne seront pas pour la
santé mais pour le porte-monnaie une eau
moins calcaire c'est des équipements
ménagers qui durent plus longtemps et
c'est aussi moins de consommation
énergétique
écoutez à ce propos l'un des vice
président en charge du syndicat
responsable du site de l'ancienne cet
avantage se traduira pour les
consommateurs par un gain financier
parce qu'aujourd'hui vous acheter du sel
adoucissant vous consommez plus
d'énergie pour chauffer faire marcher
les différents équipements
électroménagers et nous avons calculé si
vous voulez pourra foyer moyen quatre
personnes qui en moyenne consomme 120
mètres cubes d'eau par an nous avons
chiffré à environ 120 euros par an des
économies qui seront réalisées grâce à
cela à noter enfin où il fait que vous
pourrez mettre au placard les
adoucisseurs individuel que vous que
vous avez à la maison et que le calcaire
récupéré par la nouvelle unité de
louveciennes servira pour les terrains
agricoles qui ont besoin de cet apport
c'est donc une double bonne action
une double bonne action merci nicolas
pour ces précisions va parler de noël à
présent es ce que vous avez votre sapin
de noël dans son budget gelé depuis ce
week-end alors si par contre vous n'avez
pas encore finalisé l'achat du sapin
voici un reportage qui va vous aider à
faire votre choix nicolas landry est
allé rencontrer un horticulteur à
saint-nom-la-bretèche aux portes de
saint quentin en yvelines un beau sapin
pour avoir beaucoup de cas douce et la
décoration essentiel de noël avec des
critères de choix très précis bon sa
part je le choisis en fonction du volume
de la hauteur et de la verdure
ils n'ont pas tous le même verre et donc
j'ai choisi un verre qui lui sert
comment vous l'avez choisi
par sa taille mais trop gros nez trop
petit chez l'horticulteur cédric bouvier
deux choix de sapins sont possibles
l'épiça ou le nordman chacun ses
spécificités avec un prix plus élevé
pour ce dernier c'est qu un épicéa mais
moitié moins de temps à être cultivé cas
norman à norman d'un mètre cinquante un
médecin 15 faut compter entre 7 et 10
ans un épicéa en quatre ans vous en avez
un décoration d'intérieur il ya le point
ccja qui est très qui est très demandée
aux fêtes de fin d'année déjà d'une
passe qui fleurit à cette époque-ci et
en plus il a la couleur rouge rouge de
noël depuis quelques années on à la rose
de noël
l'hellébore qui est devenue une fleur
très importante pour les fêtes de fin
d'année est très en vogue couronnes de
l'avent petit sapin reconstituer
figurine du père noël cédric boully a
décidé de se diversifier dans les
produits vendus pour bien accompagner le
bout ça sent et qui dit réveillon 10
repas de fête cette année vous allez
peut-être goûter à la viande mature et
laisser vieillir le bon vin ou encore le
fromage c'est un processus qui est bien
connu dans l'hexagone mais c'est une
méthode qui s'applique aussi dorénavant
à la viande de boeuf découverte signés
camille lambert
c'est une science presque un art ces
morceaux de boeuf ont passé plus d'un
mois dans une cave réfrigérée comme le
fromage le bon vin faire vieillir la
viande demande rigueur et précision ce
processus d'affinage va permettre en
fait de sublimer certaines
caractéristiques ce qu'on appelle
organoleptiques alors l'organe au les
psy c'est la saveur c'est la texture
c'est le goût c'est l'odeur est donc ça
va surtout sublimer la tendreté de la
viande ainsi que le goût cette
maturation elle peut prendre
elle commence 2
prêt à partir de dix jours et elle peut
aller jusqu'à 30 40 50 voire pour
certains certains cas bien particuliers
120 jours certains bouchers pousse même
la maturation jusqu'à un an
l'hygiène est soigneusement contrôlée
les spécialistes jaune entre les
différents paramètres dans les caves de
maturation la température l'hygrométrie
et le temps il faut la conserver
vraiment danser car là puisque ces
câbles à vont permettre meilleure
ventilation une meilleure aération et
puis une homogénéité de température et
d'hygrométrie qui est vraiment très
importante pour réaliser ce process de
maturation toute viande ne se prête pas
à la maturation déjà ce sont les
morceaux les plus nobles
vous allez avoir la côte de boeuf
l'entrecôte principalement et des
morceaux qui contiennent un minimum de
graisse intramusculaire ce qu'on a fait
le père siad le père sillage est
important car la viande père de son os
et le gras serait parti dans les fibres
du muscle et donne ce goût si
particulier pour un kilo de ce mets
d'exception compter entre 35 à 75 euros
selon les boucheries les produits les
plus nobles peuvent grimper à plus de
1000 euros un moment de solidarité à
maurepas pour la troisième année
consécutive une grande enseigne de
jouets a décidé d'aider le secours
populaire des yvelines pour les fêtes de
fin d'année ce mercredi elle a donné
près de 2700 euros de jouer à cette
association cette dernière les utilisera
pour sa traditionnelle distribution qui
comprend à la fois à des colis repas
pour les familles ou encore donc des
cadeaux pour les enfants notre
journaliste anne leur langue et ya
recueilli quelques réactions
pour hrw et ses formidables parce qu'en
fait je crois que les parents ne
pourraient pas
suivent venir à ce genre de cadeau c'est
une association qui est basé non loin du
magasin qui je pense aussi partage des
valeurs qui sont aussi celles de picwic
qui sont des valeurs de familles qui
sont de d'offrir un cadeau de noël aux
enfants je crois que nous notre métier
c'est d'offrir un cadeau de noël à tous
les enfants et même ceux finalement qui
qui n'ont pas qu'ils n'ont pas forcément
les moyens de pouvoir le faire et ce
week end la spa aussi organise son noël
plus de 400 chiens et chats seront
proposés à l'adoption à paris place de
la république dans un refuge éphémère
nous sommes allés rencontrer
l'association sur son site de plaisir
certains de ces animaux vont faire le
déplacement jusqu'à la capitale venus à
12 ans et malgré son vieil âge elle n'a
jamais connu la chaleur d'une vraie
famille cette année la chance de peut
être retourné pour le noël des animaux
organisé par la spa elle ira à paris les
10 et 11 décembre rencontrer de futurs
adoptants alors venus et une petite
mamie de 12 ans qui est calme qui s'est
supporter la solitude qui peut vivre en
appartement par contre avec un ascenseur
puisque c'est un berger allemand donc à
la des problèmes de train arrière
donc on le sait tous yann qui cherchent
leur art un foyer calme comme vénus 4
son chien et chat venus de toute la
france seront proposés à l'adoption
le refuge sainte apolline de plaisir
emmènera une trentaine de ses
pensionnaires
en fait on se déplace on va justement
vers la population qui n'est pas
forcément véhicule et qui ne peut pas
forcément se déplacer dans nos refuges
donc on va vers eux et on leur amène nos
petits protégés
du côté des chats le public pourra
retrouver luna une siamoises de 10 ans
qui aspire elle aussi à une vie
tranquille
idéal en appartement et pour les plus
dynamiques ces jeunes voyageurs arrivent
tout juste de guadeloupe
comme il est difficile de faire des
adoptions là bas on en récupère
régulièrement donc là ils sont arrivés
ce matin
donc ils sont très mignons
visiter en famille d'accueil là bas et
puis il arrive chez nous pour qu'on ait
proposé qu'on leur trouve une famille en
2015 une soixantaine de chanceux du
refuge de plaisir ont pu passer les
fêtes en famille grâce au noël des
animaux
les bénévoles espèrent un aussi beau
cadeau cette année tous les ans la spa
recueille plus de 40 mille animaux
abandonnés
un défi sportif pour les salariés c'est
l'enjeu du trophée des entreprises qui
se tiendra à cette année le 1er juin à
saint quentin en yvelines ouvert aux
sociétés basées sur l'agglomération les
épreuves vont mettre 180 équipes de
trois personnes aux défis parmi lesquels
de la course à pied ou encore du bike
and run le départ sera donné au
vélodrome de montigny le bretonneux
écoutez la responsable de l'organisation
c'est au micro de camille lambert
on s'est rendu compte qu'il y avait peu
voire pas d'événement de ce type sur
déjà sur saint quentin mais même en
région parisienne et la question du
sport étant de plus en plus de prise en
compte au sein des entreprises pour
toutes les valeurs qu'ils véhiculent et
en termine aussi de cohésion de groupe
de team building on s'est dit en étant
le deuxième pôle économique de l'ouest
parisien
ça nous paraissait important de proposer
ce type d'événement est cette année donc
c'est la dixième édition
on termine par des nouvelles à du vendée
globe le versailles et éric bellion qui
a passé en début de semaine le cap de
bonne espérance a failli abandonner ce
mercredi le skipper a été victime d'une
avarie il a dû réparer en urgence son
safran c'est une pièce en carbone situé
à l'arrière du bateau après plus de onze
heures de travaux le navigateur du
bateau comme un seul homme a pu repartir
pour ce tour du monde en solo connectés
ça je peux vous dire que je suis
vraiment fier de ce combat là parce que
cent fois j'ai voulu abandonner en
disant que j'y arriverai pas
j'y suis depuis cinq heures du matin je
me suis battu et bon l'aventuré continue
comptant et là je peux vous dire que je
me repose un peu parce que a été un
combat dans l'est dans les vagues qui
fait frapper le tableau arrière je
trempe et ben voilà donc l'aventuré
continue sur comme un seul homme ssl
principal allez bon courage à tous ces
skippers pour ce tour du monde qui se
poursuit encore pendant plusieurs
semaines c'est la fin de ce journal
rendez vous lundi pour une nouvelle
édition demain vendredi vous avez rendez
vous avec nicolas quere lovitz pour
l'hebdo avec ses invités
il commandera à l'acte il commentera à
l'actualité de la semaine en attendant
lé programme se poursuivre sur notre
antenne
[Musique]